workshop in the
computational complexity and statistical
inference program running this semester
uh average case complexity from
cryptography to statistical learning
uh first of all a big thank you to the
organizers luca trevor sanboz barack
amit danieli
to all those folks
um uh
so uh luca's gonna say a few words uh
about the workshop i mean i guess we've
got a whole lot of familiar faces here
i'm not sure i need to go through the
logistics for you everyone's wearing
masks you're all
caught up with the food outside um
uh a big thank you also to kelani
pendland our events coordinator for all
the local arrangements
[Applause]
i'll hand over to luca uh good to see
you again sorry you can't be here in
person
thank you peter though i have my beloved
uh someone's just little cup to have a
bit of the seven sisters here in milan
so well um
yes thanks to the organizers of the
semester long program for uh having this
wonderful idea of a
workshop specifically about connections
between
cryptography and the complexity of uh
statistical problems
and thanks to all the speakers that
accepted our
invitations to
both those that were able to travel and
those that will have to
[Music]
give their talks
remotely
basically the i think with the problems
in
statistical learning
and machine learning in general
is that it seems some of them are easier
some of them are harder one would like
the theory of computational complexity
to have something to say about the
hardness of problems that
seem hard but those are problems where
in their very
definition we have to talk about
distributions over inputs and those are
all problems that are inherently
distributional problems for which an
average case analysis doesn't make a lot
of sense
unfortunately material computational
complexity has been struggling since the
80s to develop viable techniques to talk
about the
average case complexity of
distributional problems
without making a whole lot of progress
on the other hand
in cryptography
security analysis always proceeds by
again studying the
complexity of a problem that is
inherently
distribution
and so in cryptography we do have
a lot of techniques to
reduce distribution problems to one
another to establish the complexity of
distributional problems
unfortunately the thing with complexity
with cryptography is that there we are
we are allowed
to
define what is the problem what is the
distribution that we want to be
hard
and that's a lot that's very much
different from having a given
distribution problem that we would like
to analyze
but nonetheless there are a number
of conjecturally hard problems in the
cryptography are very simple and they
seem like a real starting point for
reductions and we'll see several talks
about them about problems about
random constraint satisfaction problems
simple pseudorandom generators learning
with other infinite fields or
over the reels
we'll see
something that has been done about
reductions between problems in
statistics and
machine learning for problems about
planted instances to
problems more directly related to
learning neural networks and
executing gradient descent
to have some of the full spectrum of
results in which everybody can see
something new and we lots of
tomorrow a much more traditional talk
about problems like
finding the minimum size circuit that
satisfies a certain input output
relation or
approximating the
certain resource-bounded version of
common goal of complexity those are
problems that are somewhat tangentially
related to
learning because they have to do with
the problem learning general circuits
but are also
having a
very deep and knowledgeably understood
position at the core of average case
complexity kind of
particularly on
how
and worst case assumptions relate to
average case assumptions
so i hope everybody will find something
new and something interesting something
thought for working in this workshop and
the whole three days of the workshop
will be a long uh
sort of
opportunity to
think about your conjectures think about
the new open problems
on this note tomorrow we will have a one
hour so structure session specifically
on open problems and conjectures
as you have
heard from the
someone's administration
andre and i would like to know
in advance say by end of day today by
email if you plan to talk in a tomorrow
session and roughly about
what
so we can make a
preliminary
schedule for the session a sense of how
much time to give to
each presentation
nonetheless if
tomorrow you decide the last minute
you'd like to talk i'm sure there will
be some time available at that but if
you already know that you would like to
talk please let andre and i know
okay so i hope everybody
will find out the food for thought in
this
three days and i'll just
pass the floor to the session chair to
introduce our speaker
yes let's clap towards itself
okay andre would you like to set up
okay so we're delighted to kick off the
workshop with a talk by andre bogdanov
about breaking encryption and
statistical zero knowledge please take
away andre
uh thanks a little and thanks to the
organizers for putting up this uh
nice workshop and this uh really amazing
program which where i learned a lot of
things a lot of things were new to me uh
so i think the focus so far has been
mainly on uh
problems in statistics and machine
learning
and there is this sort of very old
connection between statistics and
cryptography that goes back to the 90s
so i want to sort of talk a little bit
from this perspective
and uh sort of this is i guess well
known to
people in this room but sort of you know
statistic uh
statistical interests and cryptography
are kind of dual and diverse to each
other
uh so
in the sense that sort of the goals are
opposite right so in statistical
inference at least sort of the kinds of
questions that
people talked about
you're given some data that comes from
some distribution and then you're trying
to infer
what the parameters of the distribution
are or predict new data items that come
from the distribution
and in much of cryptography the goal is
exactly the opposite right you want to
design a distribution that is hard to
predict and so in particular the task of
encrypting data is exactly that uh when
you want to
sort of argue that your encryption
scheme is secure you want to say well if
somebody an adversary sees encryptions
random encryptions of messages
they should not be able to infer
anything about the message in fact it's
the opposite goal that they shouldn't be
able to predict anything about the
message
and sort of kind of this dual
perspective has been used to great
success to sort of argue about the
limitations of statistical inference
based on things that people did in
cryptography before
and sort of the point
the the part i want to focus more on
this talk is that somehow the standards
are a little bit different generally in
cryptography when you want to sort of
claim security for an encryption scheme
you really want to consider all
algorithms and you want to make a strong
case that's sort of no matter which
algorithm a person comes with they won't
be able to do it
uh in statistical inference sort of
you know there are these very successful
models that capture large classes of
algorithms like polynomial statistical
query sensible one and this gives us
good evidence that somehow you know
these classes of algorithms don't work
and uh you know they they expose
limitations
but sort of you know they give different
kind of different facets about the
hardness of this problem
so this is going to be a crypto talk i'm
going to mostly talk about it from the
crypto perspective and i hope in the end
to come back and speculate a little bit
about what all this means to to the
hardness of statistical learning so let
me sort of start with the grand goal of
uh sort of the foundations of crypto and
this is sort of what uh you know we all
know and have wanted to do for many
years is that we want to basic your
crypto on sort of the the strongest
possible hardness assumption and for
crypto this would be the assumption that
p does not equal np we know that they're
equal then there is there is no crypto
it's not possible to do anything and
this was even pointed out in the seminal
paper of diffie and hellmann which is
from from the 70s sort of they foresaw
this connection and they first saw the
obstacle about why is it that we cannot
get it why what is it that prevents us
from getting secure crypto from
p does not equal to np and
sort of as people have studied this
problem we somehow understand the
barriers in going from here to there
and there are several levels of them
sort of there are several barriers one
has to overcome
uh there is this very nice paper of
impiazzo from the mid
90s where he sort of points out the
different barriers but one is that sort
of and this was even known early on is
that there are two steps one has to
overcome one has to go from he does not
equal np which talks about worst case
hardness of problems to average case
hardness and then there is sort of the
other thing about how one goes from
average case hardness to secure crypto
and sort of to give you a little bit
more detail about this average case
hardness it sort of comes in two flavors
it comes in sort of the flavor of i
think what people mostly would call
refutation hardness which is sort of
you know i want to design an algorithm
which is always correct but it can say i
don't know some fraction of the time and
it it handles average case hard
instances
and the one that we need from crypto is
a heuristic hardness an algorithm that's
somehow you know can can give the wrong
answer from time to time but it just
happens to be right with
most of the time or some some
non-negligible fraction of the time
and sort of
uh
a lot of the the work in sort of why so
so
somehow a lot of the work we have that
study this connection is negative and it
has focus on this part over here right
we have a lot of excuses why we cannot
go from p does not equal np to even this
kind of first stage of average case
hardness
and i'm not going to talk about this in
this talk and the reason i'm not going
to talk about this is because tomorrow
there is a talk by shuichi hirahara who
had this amazing result about four years
ago
that showed that essentially all the
excuses we have for this are nonsense
so what he showed is not exactly that
you can do this
but he showed something very related he
showed that you can't have a worst case
average case reduction
for some problem which is sort of looks
like going from p does not equal np to
refutation hardness
and this is this uh
minimum
time-bounded polymorph complexity
problem
so sort of just
yeah he's going to talk about it
tomorrow so i think you should really i
hope so i think this is the talk you
should attend but just to sort of give
you a sense of the obstacle that is
overcome
in this
is that
what's special about this problem is
that
uh it's sort of i'm going to start
drawing this complexity picture so there
is p there is np and there is co and p
right and p is the problems that have
efficient proofs and point p is the
problems that have efficient refutations
so this problem for which he does the
worst case to average case reduction
is believed
to be inside np but not inside co np
and sort of all the obstacles all the
excuses that we had before about not
being able to do a reduction actually
applied said that problems for which we
cannot do them has to be in the
intersection so in this part over here
so sort of somehow this worst case to
average case barrier that we had for
many years has in some sense been
overcome
we don't know how to do crypto from it
we don't know how to go all the way down
but this is not what i'm going to talk
about what i want to do is i want to do
a little bit of a different perspective
today so what i want to ask is the
following question so
we've been building so in particular the
kinds of crypto that we can build we use
problems like shortest independent
vector problem which is a worst case
problem
learning with errors which is an average
case problem these are problems that
reside in np intersect go and pay
and the question i want to talk about
today
is
whether we can build secure cryptography
let's let's let's have slightly more
modest goals let's say we don't want to
build it based on the assumption p does
not equal np can we take anything which
is even conjecturally outside np
intersect q and p
and and and build secure crypto from it
and
uh privately crypto is a bit boring so
today i'm going to focus on public key
encryption
um so this class np intersect coinp is a
little bit hard to think about sort of
how do you argue that
sort of something is outside np
intersect currently so instead of
talking about np intersect co-np i'm
going to talk about something
slightly smaller
which actually captures a lot of what's
going on inside there and this is this
beautiful complexity class called
statistical zero knowledge so i'm going
to explain what this is if you haven't
seen it before
but sort of this is my mental picture of
what it happens it captures not
everything but a lot of what's going on
inside and painters are currently
yes
okay so but the the
barriers are for actually
uh anti-intersecting or it could be that
all the barriers to statistical zero
knowledge oh it's a good question so i'm
not going to make this distinction right
now
today i'm going to talk about
statistical sort of statistic what sort
of what you can break using statistical
zero knowledge so the way that i'm going
to frame the question is like this
suppose statistical zero knowledge was
easy
okay so i could also say suppose np
intersect when p was easy
okay if i had this power what kind of
cryptography can i break with it
okay and the reason i'm focusing on
statistical zero knowledge i'll show you
in a minute is because
it's a little bit hard for me to think
about what it means for np intersect
point p to be easy i mean you can define
some kind of oracle that solves problem
inside np intercept quantity but it's
complicated on the other hand
statistical zero knowledge is a very
very very nice complexity class
so if you haven't seen it or if you
don't know much about it
let me tell you what it is
and
the nice thing about it is that it has
two definitions
uh so this is sort of the
standard definition this is how it was
defined first
by goldreich michali goldbacher mcgalley
and rakoff
it's a
class of problems that have not written
proofs like np but interactive proofs
and these interactive proofs have an
extra feature which is that the verifier
finds out nothing about the interaction
and what turns out to be important is
that this nothing has to be defined
statistically meaning that whatever the
verifier sees from the interaction he
can create the same distribution of
views on his own
uh
in a statistical way which is
statistically close that what he
observed before
um
okay
um
yeah feel free to yes
so you talked about two types of
productions
and now i want to kind of switch the
perspective and ask
you know suppose we want to overcome the
second barrier suppose we want to build
encryption now i want to look at sort of
what we have done what kind of
encryptions we can we have built and
which of them do or candidate are
possible ways to overcome this barrier
right so so that's uh
thanks
please feel free to to ask any questions
it's
i guess this talk is a little bit
different in both perspective and
content from what we have seen before so
so
feel free to hijack it and take the
in a different direction if you think
it's more interesting
so um
so this is one definition
and then there is a different definition
which turns out to be equivalent which
is actually very convenient
and this is from the work of uh sahaja
yoga in 99 who showed that we can
actually
think of this statistical zero knowledge
through a complete problem
and the complete problem has a very
simple description
we are given two
samplers for two distributions
okay let me call them a and b
so they're circuits
and then what you have to decide is
whether the distributions these they
sample distributions so the input is
just a random string right the output is
some string of the same length in both
you have to decide whether they sample
the same distribution or very different
distribution or sort of
if you do it with parameters if you they
sample distributions which are
statistically close or statistically far
from one another
and sort of if you think about mp
completeness usually use complete
problems to argue that something is hard
but actually this is going to be a
convenient definition for us to put
things in statistical zero knowledge so
if i can reduce whatever i'm trying to
do to this problem namely if i have an
oracle that can do this
then if i can use this oracle to
solve my problem break my encryption in
this case then that would be evidence
that or it would put this problem inside
statistical neurology
no no
the samplers output samples from
distributions right
so you can think of the output of the
sampler as the description of a
distribution so there are statements
about those distributions whether
they're statistically close or
statistically far
so it's actually a very natural
problem for
statistical inference right
but it's it's a hard one
so i want to kind of do a historical
tour mostly tell you about things that
are known and maybe say a little bit of
some new observations in the end
about which of the encryption schemes
can we break with an oracle that allows
us to distinguish between such pairs of
distributions
so i'm going to do some examples
the first example i want to talk about
is algamal encryption so this is sort of
one of the
i guess early encryption schemes which
is based on the hardness of
decisional difficult assumptions so the
hardness of sort of distinguishing
discrete logs
and for what i'm going to talk about
it's not going to be too important sort
of why this encryption is secure because
we're going to after all break it using
our oracle so it's just the mechanics
that are going to matter more
and the way that it works is g here is
the generator of some cyclic group
and then
the public key
is just g raised to some random number
which you call the secret key
okay so that's that's that's how this
looks like it's it's algebra
if i want to encrypt a message what i do
is i take the generator raise it to some
random power
and i take the public key raise it to
the same random power and multiply it by
the message where again i think of the
message as being some group element
um
and
this allows me to decrypt the message if
i know the secret key
because i can undo this this operation
that i did on the left if i raise the
first part to the secret key and divide
i get the message back
that's the logic behind the decryption
at least
and what i want to sort of argue now is
that
if i have a statistical zero knowledge
oracle
then i can break this encryption what
does it mean to break this encryption it
means that i can distinguish between
encryptions of two different messages
here i'm going to call them one and two
for convenience
so how do i use this oracle to
distinguish between the two encryptions
no
when i'm given with the task of
distinguishing two encryptions i'm given
a string right this is the encryption i
have what the oracle allows me to do it
allows me to distinguish between
samplers
so somehow if i want to use this oracle
i need to take this string
and turn it into a sampler or i need to
take a sample and turn it into a sampler
for producing
sort of samples from the same
distribution
and in this case there is an easy way to
do it i think some of you see it already
right what i can do is i can
take
the cipher text which is this pair x
comma y
and i raise it to some random power r
prime
okay
which is independent of what it was
before
in the case i had an encryption of one
what happens here is that
this exponent r gets re-randomized
right so i end up with something which
is g raised to the power r times r prime
and public key raised to the power r
times r prime
okay so if i think of this now as a
circuit
that maps
this c r prime
into a new
encryption it's a re-randomization of
the old encryption right it's something
that takes a sample and produces samples
from the same distribution
okay on the other hand i have a way of
producing the same encryption so i can
compare this circuit to the circuit that
just maps
r
to an encryption
of
one
with randomness r
if this was an encryption of one these
two circuits would sample the same
distribution
if this was an encryption of two let's
say they would sample two distributions
which are very far apart
and that's exactly the description of
the statistical distance problem
so that's one reason why you can use
this kind of oracle to break encryptions
okay
and sort of the consequence of this is
that
actually if you
state it in more general terms you can
say that any encryption method which is
re-randomizable meaning that given an
encryption i can
generate
sort of random encryptions that look
exactly like it you can break it for
this reason in statistical zero
knowledge and sort of i had a paper from
some time ago with chinh holby where we
showed that
actually any encryption scheme which is
homomorphic
uh not to give the details now is sort
of you can show that it's always going
to be randomizable so somehow this says
that
if your encryption scheme is too strong
if it supports homomorphism if it
supports too much functionality then
it's not a good candidate for being
secure based on p does not equal np it
can be broken with this kind of work
example two
this is an encryption scheme of regeth
so this is sort of the famous lwe based
encryption
and it turns out that this one too can
be broken in statistical zero knowledge
but for a different reason
so
i'm not going to tell you what this
scheme looks like
sort of i'm just going to tell you what
the public key in the scheme looks like
and the public key has to do with the
learning with errors assumption what
does the learning with errors
assumptions say it says that if i take
a random matrix at all matrix m by n
matrix
with values
in zq for some modulus q
and
i take some random linear combination of
its columns and and i add a bit of noise
to it okay that's what the right hand
side is going to look like
that this is going to be
indistinguishable
from what would have happened if the
right hand side was completely random
and independent from the left okay
so this is very much
like uh you know statistical inference
hypothesis right
i have some secret key
that tells me what linear combinations
i'm taking and i cannot distinguish sort
of this alternative hypothesis that the
right hand side are noisy samples from
this distribution
from them being completely random
so
what i'm going to sort of show you is
that
what you can do using a statistical
distance oracle
is you can distinguish between the null
hypothesis and the alternative
hypothesis and what i'm not going to
show you but what reggae showed is that
this is in fact sufficient
uh to break the encryption scheme so
it's neces so the security of this is
both necessary and sufficient for the
security of encryption
the reason for this is that there is an
addition some search to decision
reduction which says that if i can break
these two distributions if i can
distinguish between those two
distributions then i can recover the
secret key and once i know the secret
key then everything is insecure
so how can i distinguish between these
two distributions using the statistical
distance oracle
and this is a very nice idea of
goldrich and goldbuster who gave
actually a more general protocol
and what they say is what we're going to
look at
is we're going to look at the span of
the columns of this matrix
on the one hand and the span of the
columns of this matrix plus the vector b
on the other hand
and you get a picture that kind of looks
like this
in the first case where you have this
alternative hypothesis
these two spans are going to be close to
one another
why because the second one is just
obtained from the first one by adding
some small noise to it
okay in the second case
i add something completely random
so
they're going to be far from one another
so how can i distinguish between these
two cases what i do is sort of here is
uh
here are the two distributions if we
think of it in terms of distributions
i take a sample either from
here or from here
okay
and then i add a bunch of i add a little
bit of noise to it so i shifted by some
vector
okay some some gaussian let's see
so in this case the distributions that i
get are going to be close to one another
because somehow the noise is going to
you
know like make these two
subspaces look the same
in this case because they're very far
already actually if the noise doesn't
have too much magnitude they're still
going to be very distinct so i'm going
to get to distributions which are very
far apart from one another
so that's the reason why uh
reg f encryption you can break it also
with the statistical zero knowledge
oracle
well
okay
now i want to talk about the third
example which is a little bit less
familiar but
i think it's interesting
and the reason it's interesting is sort
of
because
all this example involves some kind of
choice of parameters and somehow the way
that this is designed
ends up being that
the choice of parameters that you need
to make
to
to make the encryption work is exactly
the same as the one that puts it in
statistical zero knowledge
so somehow there seems to be some reason
why
some deeper reason why this game is
breakable in statistical zero knowledge
i don't really understand why but sort
of i want to show you the calculation
and and and try to reason it through
so this is an encryption scheme that was
proposed by
michelle eknovich actually it predates
the regular scheme
and um
it has kind of a similar
the algebra is is related
but the
domain structure is different in the
sense that this scheme doesn't work over
zq or two is large that's that's
necessary for
uh even to make sense of what rig of
encryption does here everything is over
z2 so all these things belong in
z2 their bits
zeros and one
and
when i do addition over z2 right it's
like the xor operation either flip a bit
with some probability or i leave it
alone
um so in the electric knowledge scheme
what the public key is
it's a random matrix so you can think of
the rows as being some kind of random
vectors mod 2.
and then i have
an extra vector at the end
which is a linear combination a random
linear combination of the matrix plus
some noise and this noise is going to be
the secret key okay so we'll figure out
what the nature of what what this noise
needs to look like exactly later but you
can think of it essentially sort of when
you do things over zf z2 there is one
very natural way to generate noise which
is to flip each bit independently with
some probability p
and if you want that's pretty much the
only way
the only thing you can do
how do i encrypt the message
well
i'm going to tell you it's a different
way that you encrypt a zero message on a
one message so i'm going to tell you how
you do both and i do it by sort of
taking this public matrix this is the
public key and multiplying it by
something
okay so i'm going to multiply it by some
vector
if i want to encrypt a 0 what i do
is i take some vector which is in the
dual space of this so something that
will multiply to 0
as inner product 0
and then i'm going to add some extra
noise to it somehow the purpose of this
extra noise is to hide the fact that i'm
in the duel
okay and then
what aleknovich does is he reduces the
security of this to to some assumption
which is possible
okay but it's not going to be too
important for us
if i want to encrypt a 1 what i do is i
take this matrix
and i just multiply the whole thing by a
random vector like completely random 0 1
vector
so now i have to tell you how the
decryption works sort of why why why you
would expect even this to be functional
and the reason that the decryption works
is because there is a gap between what
happens
when i multiply the secret key with an
encryption of zero
and when i multiply the secret key with
an encryption of one
when i multiplied by an encryption of
zero what happens is that
because this c lives in the dual space
is going to vanish when i multiply it by
the c
right the secret key is just some linear
combination of the rows of this matrix
so that part is going to vanish and
what's going to be left over is just
uh
the dot product of the secret key and
the noise
well when i encrypt the one
when i try to decrypt
a one
what i get is
the inner product of the secret key
whatever it is by something random
so
if i end up picking the parameter so
that there is a gap between these two
cases
then i can decrypt how do i ensure there
is a gap if i can ensure that the
support of the secret key and the
support of the noise are typically
disjoint then there is going to be a gap
between the two cases
right
so i need two these two to be
typically disjoint
so this is not a perfect decryption in
the sense that here half of the time i'm
going to get the zero half of the time
i'm going to get a one but then i can
play the usual trick like encrypting
multiple times and so on to increase the
security but i need to have some kind of
noticeable gap here for me to be able to
tell whether i have encrypted the one or
zero to begin with
so now comes the part which i think is
somewhat interesting
is that
in order to have this first property in
order for this to be typically disjoint
if each of them is some kind of random
noise
then at least one of them
needs to have
they
think of them as being binomial samples
right needs to have probability one over
square root of n
right if both of them are bigger than
one over square root of n then i'm going
to get a collision i'm very likely to
get the collision
but
if
this has probability one over square
root of n
then it turns out that i can use that
in both cases to put this to break this
description in using the statistical
distance oracle why can i do it well
because i can use a very sim similar
trick to what gold drag and gold buster
used so here the distributions are a
little bit different because they're
distributions over bits but you get the
same phenomenon which is that c
okay say
um
say the secret key
is comes from comes from a distribution
that looks like this
so then what i can do is i can sort of
take my public key matrix
and you know do the same trick i did
before i'm not going to explain it but
just add some noise to it right and the
noise that the extra noise i'm going to
add is just going to be say i flip each
bit individually with an extra
probability one third
uh in one of the distributions if i look
at the distributions that comes from the
secret key
the effect i get from doing this is as
if i was adding
somehow a random vector which has square
root of n once
with a random vector that has n over
three ones
and this is statistically close
to a random vector that has one third
once because square root of n is kind of
within the standard deviation
right on the other hand if i add this to
a random vector i'm going to notice that
there is a big difference right because
the number of ones will will jump from
one third to one half
so i think it's kind of curious that
one over square root of n is kind of the
exact point at which this happens and
this is the parameter that you need to
use for the security of encryption that
allows you to break it in statistical
zero knowledge
finally the last example i want to talk
about
has to do with this continuous lwe
problem so this is something that
we heard about in other talks in this
workshop
so it's this wonderful problem which was
introduced by
bruno regev song and tang
and the reason they introduced this
problem was precisely because they were
motivated by
hardness of learning mixtures of
gaussian so so it has a learning
theoretic motivation
uh so what is the continuous lw problem
if you didn't hear it yet so this is
sort of the picture
is that
i sample
a vector now it's going to be
all the coordinates are going to be
numbers
right real numbers
and all but one of them are going to be
continuous gaussians
okay except the last one what the last
one is going to be is going to be kind
of like a discrete gaussian slightly
thick and discrete gaussian
which uh has the same
or like very close to the same
parameters as the continuous gaussian
same mean same standard deviation
and
what
this assumption says is that
if i see any number of samples from this
distribution
they're going to be computationally
indistinguishable of what i see
if all of them were continuous normals
meaning that it's a normal distribution
now this is clearly false the way i
state because
if you just look at the last coordinate
here you're going to see discrete
behavior in one case continuous behavior
in the other case we can tell them apart
but what they say is you do the sort of
simplest thing you can to hide this
which is you just apply a random
rotation
so you just do sort of this hiding in
some random direction
and then it becomes uh computationally
indistinguishable to tell
any number of samples between these two
distributions which one they came from
so what does this have to do with crypto
well
so this is this is the hypothesis they
have
well
it turns out that
there is a very old crypto system that
was based based on this assumption
even before this assumption was made
and this is the high tie and work crypto
system that from 1997
okay so
they had they they wrote it a bit
differently they used different set of
parameters so i'm not going to go into
the differences but i'm going to just
take this assumption and kind of try to
plug in what they did to see what we get
what what are the consequences that we
get from this
and i'm actually not going to present to
you the original i tied work which is a
little bit complicated
i'm going to present to you some
simplification
which has some drawbacks but it's part
of some
sort of work in progress i'm doing with
uh
uh miguel quito novel charlotte hoffman
uh devi ka sharma and alan rosen
so here is what the
crypto system will look like
so think of it sort of
what is this hclw problem you're giving
a bunch of samples
i can write these samples as being
columns of some matrix
so i have some matrix p k
i'm going to call this the public key
matrix
right each column of this is an
independent sample from this
distribution
okay so that's the public key
the secret key is just the hidden
direction it's the direction in which
these discrete samples occur
how do i encrypt
so it's going to be a little bit like
what happens in dialect knowledge
encryption
uh to encrypt the zero what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take these public
keys
these samples
and i'm going to multiply it on the
right
by a random
plus minus one vector
okay
and then i'm going to apply some
rounding which i will tell you about
what it is exactly in a minute but it's
not going to be too important for now
you can ignore it
if i want to encrypt the one what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to just
take a uniform normal sample
which is independent of the public key
so if i want to encrypt a zero i'm going
to multiply the public key by something
on the right okay this is going to be an
encryption of zero
encryption of one is going to be
something that has
the same length but it's completely
independent of the public key it's just
a random vector
how does decryption work
well
i do the natural thing is i know the
direction of the secret key and i
multiply it by
the encryption that i get
so if i had what i had was an encryption
of zero
if you ignore this rounding
which sort of
i will tell you what you can in a second
what happens here is essentially you're
multiplying the secret key
by the public key
by this
randomness key that you used for the
encryption
right and the product of the secret can
the public key reveals exactly
sort of the hidden component of the
vector
right so this part
is going to give you something that
looks like this
right you get distinct samples from this
distribution right you get something
which is
concentrated around the integers
so now if i take this and multiply it by
a plus minus one vector what do i get i
get something which is very close to an
integer
right i get samples which are close to
an integers and then i take a plus minus
one combination of them so i get the
sample something which is close to an
integer
if i do the same thing with an
encryption of one this thing here is
completely random
i multiply it by plus minus one
i get some gaussian right so typically a
gaussian is not going to be close to an
integer it's going to be far
and this is sort of how i can
distinguish encryptions of zero from
encryption of one
what is this rounding function
it turns out that you have to put in
some rounding function if you want to
argue security
and
sort of the property that we want is
that
okay so let me tell you what it doesn't
then i'll try to argue why it's secure
um
so first of all the way i'm going to
implement it
is i take this vector
which has
entries which are real numbers
and the way that i'm going to round them
up is i'm going to divide up the line
into
intervals
where the gaussian weight of each
interval is the same and there are going
to be some polynomial number of them so
you can think of them there being us
some kind of pullian
intervals
here all of them have the same gaussian
weight
and the way that i'm going to round say
a vector that gets one sample here one
sample here one sample here
i'm just going to map it
to
the bucket right so if i label these
buckets one two three four five
i'm going to round this to two
i'm going to round this to six and so on
okay so that's how the rounding happens
so two things that fall into the same
interval get get rounded to the same
value
and it turns out that the property of
this is that
it's pseudorandom
in the sense that
if instead of the public key matrix i
used
a purely normal matrix
then
the rounded encryption of zero and the
rounded encryption of one would be
statistically closed even given the
matrix itself
and sort of using this you can then do a
security argument which is not too
important for us you can show that this
implies that
encryption is
and encryption of one are
indistinguishable
they're close to one another
computationally for an adversary that
that can see both
um what does this have to do
with
uh
statistical distance and statistical
zero knowledge
well i claim that this variability
to make the encryption secure
will gives us a way to break the scheme
of statistical zero knowledge and to do
this i'm going to describe to you a
protocol that
that puts this problem in statistical
zero knowledge
so
instead of giving you the reduction
which you can also do i'm just going to
describe to you
the the the proof system
so what does this proof system do
it will allow us to distinguish a matrix
of
hclwe samples
from a purely random matrix
okay so how does it happen
well
the prover and the verifier both have
one of these two as an input
and the verifier wants to know which one
he has
right
so he takes the matrix as the public key
he doesn't know if it's a real public
key or just some some random data
and he encrypts some random message
okay and then he sends this to the
approver and tells the prover tell me
what the message is
okay
if
x happened to be the public key itself
then this is a legitimate
high tide work encryption
okay
and then the prover can decrypt so he
can figure out what this message was he
can send him some emprem which equals to
him and then the verifier is going to
accept
okay so if x
is the public key
then the verifier will
accept
with high probability
if x is a random matrix
then what happens
well
that's exactly what we showed in that
case
is that encryptions of 0
when you use a random matrix as the
public key are statistically close to
encryptions of one
okay
so then the approver
cannot tell
encryptions of zero
from encryptions of one
and finally why is it statistical zero
knowledge
because in the first case
the verifier already knew what he was
going to hear
right he could have predicted that he
was going to get the answer that he he
he
that he produced
so
uh
that's exactly the statistical zero
knowledge property
okay
so
what this shows is that
this hclw problem
actually
lies in the class statistical zero
knowledge
i didn't quite show you how to break the
encryption i only showed you that you
can distinguish a public key from a
random one and actually i'm not exactly
sure how to break the encryption
um you need to do more work
so there is some issue it's work in
progress so it's it's not it's not
completely figured out but i want to
focus on this aspect now
right
so what regephetal did in their paper is
they started with some lattice
assumption shortest independent vector
problem or whatnot and they showed that
you can derive this
clw and hclwe problems from it
and
you know
there is also this other problem which
is called lwe which has been used for a
long time
but so far we don't know sort of how
these two are related from one another
and somehow what this shows is that
sort of just about reasoning about how
encryption schemes are based on those
problems work
you can
draw the conclusion
that all of these problems are actually
cannot be too hard they all fall into
the statistical zero knowledge class
so now i want to speculate a little bit
about what this means yes hey andre i
think there was a question in the in the
zoom maybe
michael can i meet himself and ask
yes
great thanks uh are any of these
problems known to be hard for sdk
um well they're average case problems so
i don't even know what it means for them
to be hard for average case sdk okay but
can you reduce uh can you reduce this
statistical distance to
you know promise versions of any of them
or something
you need a distribution for statistical
distance to do that
so i'm not exactly sure what would be an
actual distributional variant of the
statistical distance problem okay so so
no
no
great thank you
uh okay yeah yeah i'm almost done i for
the rest i just want to speculate a
little bit about sort of how this
relates to
statistical computational gaps
so sort of
you know so a lot of i guess what people
try to do or at least the people i have
talked to
in this program is you try to sort of
figure out what are these different kind
of statistical computational problems
what kind of how hard they are how hard
they are relative to each other try to
do reductions try to do
hardness against some bounded class of
adversaries
and
sort of here is sort of one argument why
maybe
this hclwe problem might be easier not
as hard as the other problems that
people are looking at right we have this
whole class of problems and i just chose
the ones i heard about it's not
something i know much about
these kinds of problems are np problems
right i can prove to you that a random
graph has a planted clique i don't know
how to refute it i don't know how to
prove to you that it doesn't have one
right i don't know how to put it in sdk
can i come up with a protocol that shows
me that a random graph has a click
without learning anything about this
clip
so somehow there is some kind of
you know complexity the role of
complexity theory is that it somehow
tells you something about the relative
hardness of this problem right
if planted click we don't expect it to
be an np intersect point p then we know
that we cannot expect to have say a
reduction between planted clique from
planted clique to
hclwe right and so i think sort of now
that
i guess people have a very good sense
about that these problems are hard for
polynomial time algorithms or for for
some restricted polynomial time
algorithms sort of one natural question
is what is their relative hardness
and somehow figuring out sort of
if i give access to an sdk oracle or if
i give access to a co np oracle then can
i maybe solve these problems in some
range of parameters that i don't know
how to solve just in polynomial time
that that might give us some extra
information about about the hardness of
these problems
and sort of one very nice example that
sort of is again old work of this type
is this work on
um on on refuting random three set right
which is something that
a lot of you have been involved with
and the picture there is right that
if i take a random three set instance
and i increase the number of clauses
uh initially it's statistically hard
right if i have
fewer than
theta n like
i'm not going to talk about the constant
here which
it's impossible to um
i mean it's not unsatisfiable it is
satisfiable so
sort of the problem of sort of
certifying that that it's unsatisfiable
doesn't make sense
uh if i have a lot of them right if i
have more than enter the 1.5
then there has been a lot of work sort
of starting about 20 years ago that
shows that i do have algorithms that
certifies that this random formula is
unsatisfiable
and then there is sort of this range in
the middle which i think sort of there
has been a lot of explanation as to sort
of why why why
why it might be hard to do it
but there is sort of this other
interesting phenomenon that occurs which
is this uh
work of phi gekkim and offec where they
show that if i give you access to a
co-np oracle right or i mean for
refutation i can think of it as an np
oracle right if i can
non-deterministically write down some
kind of certificate then that can help
you go beyond
this close to variable ratio so there is
something like below that for which
there is an algorithm that takes some
certificate which i don't know how to
compute efficiently that convinces me
that this formula is unsatisfiable
right and somehow that paints a much
richer a richer picture about sort of
the hardness of this problem
right and somehow i guess one natural
question is whether we would expect
something like this to happen
for for other like take take your
favorite problem for the list and and
see and see if you can get it
and sort of uh
related question which is in some sense
a harder question is whether you can
come up with statistical zero knowledge
proofs that
so statistical zero knowledge has this
beautiful property that is closed under
complements so coming up with the proof
that the graph has the click
in statistical zero knowledge
automatically gives you a refutation
right so so so it's it's it's it's very
powerful like that
and can we come up with sort of some
kind of statistical zero knowledge for
this alternative hypothesis which would
maybe for at least for some setting of
parameters sure that these problems
might not be as hard
uh as we might expect and sort of going
through crypto is
maybe one way of doing this maybe you
try to build some encryption scheme and
then try to break the encryption scheme
that might put the statistical zero
knowledge but you can also try to reason
about it directly
and see if anything can come out of that
um thanks sorry for running a little bit
over there
thanks andre for the for the really
informative and wonderful talk um if if
there are questions from the live
audience please raise your hand and i'll
bring you the mic and also if there are
questions in the zoom audience feel free
to
remove yourself and ask maybe after we
finish the live audience questions
so there is a question
can you bring factoring grace encryption
that was asked by benny
uh i don't know actually this is not a
comprehensive survey i didn't go through
i don't know about factoring-based
encryption it's a good question
the other one i don't know is code-based
encryption like mclean's encryption
not sure about those so it's not meant
to be comprehensive
but those those are good questions also
yeah quick question so um you put
planted clique and all these other
planted statistical problems in np but
but not in cohen p
um is there some
reason to to believe that planetary is
not an sdk
that's speculation but
i don't know i mean yeah i mean the only
so
okay so i was really kind of my my my
the reason i did that is because there
is this really
i would say beautiful but crazy
algorithm of
an effect for random threesome so
it looks very non-obvious to me maybe if
you know what you're doing it looks
obvious but
you know
i i don't know anything like that per
click for example right so
i don't right now i i don't see any
evidence why it shouldn't be there but
maybe maybe i'm wrong maybe this is
something that people have not thought
about but it's a good question right
okay cool thanks
your speculation
any more questions from the live
audience
museum audience
well maybe just a comment that got all
the
evidence of hardness for uh or some of
the evidence of hardness for a twenty
click
is coming from
sort of
difficulty of
reputation that we
[Music]
i call the integrated gaps for
relaxations are kind of saying that it's
hard to find certificates of
[Music]
the graph doesn't have a large platy
clip
it's not the same as saying that
perhaps there are certificates that are
themselves hard to find
but
somehow it does seem to be
[Music]
hard to review the existence of large
clicks
if there's no uh no more comments or
questions from the audience and maybe we
can take the rest offline and thank
andre one more time
[Applause]